for a lot of startups I really see that
the focus is more on how am I going to
you know get this big piece of this you
know sort of big market share instead of
you know am I really creating something
that's going to be a value to people is
there a need for it can I actually
deliver on that need and am I willing to
start slow and grow slow and make
something sustainable versus make
something that's going to get flipped
quickly I can tell you that my husband
and I we did everything from sweeping
the floor to cleaning the toilets to you
know putting the software on the
computers to bind the computers to
writing the curriculum to teaching I
think the typical you know MBA kind of
approaches you know find a market
evaluate how big the market is write a
business plan figure out you know how
you can tap in to getting some of that
market share and I've never approached
our business like that I watch a lot of
businesses where they get an idea but
they're reliant on all kinds of other
people doing every piece of it and they
don't really necessarily have a big role
in the mechanics of it and I think there
is a lot of value in knowing all the
different aspects of your of your
business and knowing that you can kind
of do it yourself